the human mind can only perceive three
dimensions of physical space and then
the fourth dimension of time so again
space and time is the space in which we
dwell the dimension in which we live we
can't see or perceive other dimensions
so for the time being we are limited to
this four dimensional reality and what's
really interesting is our capacity to
pattern that four dimensional reality
and one of the reasons that I love
things like music is that music and
cinema and media is a kind of painting
in time you know whereas other artwork
like if you look at a painting on the
wall that is a static 2d image that is
not necessarily an experience that
unfolds in time it's an experience that
unfolds in space but music music is a
pattern slice of space and time music is
a subjective experience that you
actually step into and that actually
unfolds in the dimension in which we
actually live and breathe which is that
four dimensional reality so when you
talk about the power of rhythm when you
talk of a power of collective ecstasy
why people go to concerts why people go
to festivals because the musicians
essentially start by instrumental rhythm
so all of a sudden they create a
collective synchronized rhythm that
again is patterned in space and in time
and you're hearing it and it loops
around it's like ducking back
that's the bet that that's that so he
starts to pattern the rhythm that a
fools in space and time and then you
invite the audience to step into it's
all of a sudden everybody becomes
synchronized you know so we all become
one thing and that's what's called
collective experience and in that
ecstatic in that merger where everybody
becomes synchronized under one patterned
experience that unfolds in space and in
time is when music purges us it's when
music leads to that aesthetic arash that
consummation we pop out on the other
side of that experience saying oh my god
that festival was amazing I feel so
connected to the people the vibes were
so good you had to be there to know what
I feel these experiences are ineffable
they are beyond articulation words do
not give them justice we can't just tile
the experience over with description you
have to see it to believe it you have to
experience to know what I'm talking
about this the ability of these of these
musical ecstatics of this capacity of
music and concert and vibe and people
together to create these shared ecstasy
this uh electronic Buddhism in which the
self vanishes is one way in which we
escape death it's one way in which we
pierce the finite for a second we become
infinite and this oh this is a beautiful
thing it's why I patterned playlists of
music on my phone that's why I hang out
with friends and always want to play the
music in the background I mean this is
what we do we pattern we colonize we
decorate we architect we stage space and
time we are four dimensional engineers
my friends
you